[Music]
well i found this article earlier today
dave and it was interesting because i
found some conflicting news so maybe you
can help me sort this out here's one
from fox business which was encouraging
more americans optimistic about their
finances in 2022 despite inflation
so inflation's rising at the fastest
pace in decades it says which means
consumers are paying more for rent
utilities groceries than ever before
plus federal student loan payments
restart this year potentially impacting
financial stability of millions of
borrowers however a new survey from ally
bank shows that most americans are
optimistic about their finances despite
all of this
more than half 53 percent of respondents
said they're confident about their
personal financial standing 59 believe
they'll be better off financially a year
from now and two-thirds 65 said they'll
likely achieve their financial goals for
2022 even with record high inflation so
people
out there are optimistic and even with
the fact that they've gone further in
debt in 2021 than at any time in history
that's consumer
here's what we're seeing from uh reuters
here u.s household debt increased by one
trillion dollars in 2021 the most since
2007. higher borrowing was fueled in
part by rising prices as consumers cope
with strongest inflation seen in nearly
four decades and households supported by
increased savings and higher incomes
seem to be handling the larger debt
loads well so far
so far
so this brings me to my next point dave
i'm curious
so far you've seen some things in your
day uh not trying to age you here but
you you've been through 2008 you've been
through a real recession and this is
saying the debt has increased the most
since 07 right before our last big
recession do you feel like we're heading
towards another one based on these
numbers
well i don't know
i don't know the answer on that
economists and weather forecasters only
people can be wrong all the time and
keep their jobs but um job to have that
but the uh uh uh
the thing that is is
that all that always does run parallel
with this okay is
if my income is high enough and i can
keep spending even money i don't have by
going further into debt then i can
ignore inflation and i can ignore the
fact that i'm going further in debt than
i ever have in my life and i can ignore
the fact that the united states of
america is going further in debt than it
has ever gone in
that the deficit has doubled in one
decade
doubled the amount of debt we're in in
the united states has doubled the united
states government has doubled the debt
and that pulls money out of the economy
so when the u.s
borrows money using bonds
and parks it on the sidelines they
borrow
you know trillion dollars here a
trillion dollars there and they park
that money over on the shelf
it's no longer out here moving around
doing things it's sitting over here
they're sidelining it they're
shrinking the money supply by sucking
the marrow out of the bones of the
economy with the borrowing for the
united states government that's what
they're doing then add to that the
consumer's doing the same stupid thing
only the consumer's stimulating the
economy because they're buying things in
the economy and that's cycling that
money cycling so when they spend money
on a car even if it's borrowed money
that car purchase goes into a car
company which goes into car company
salaries which goes back into the rest
that guy working at the car company on
the toyota line can go out and buy a
stake you know and which by the way
doubled too and so because they must
have universal wage and at the cattle
farm so um you know wages are impacting
all of these prices left and right so
we're making more spending more
and
spending more due to inflation as well
and so what we've got here is we've got
a recipe for a comeuppance
it's a good way to say it uh sounds like
winnie the pooh yeah come up and a
comeuppance is coming it's an f it's a
heffalump it's a comeuppance is coming
up
we've got low interest rates that's
what's happening because you know what
you're doing is think about this just on
an individual level all right think
about your friend
who's borrowing himself into oblivion
he's going to get a car payment he's
going vacation on a credit card
and you can you can just watch him he's
heading to the wall he's going to hit
the wall he's gonna hit the financial
wall and you can't stop him because he
feels good because he's making more
money never made in his life because he
just got out of college
and he got a big job
but he's spending more he's spending
like he's in congress and a comeuppance
is coming you know that on an individual
basis and that's what this says on a
macro basis wow so it doesn't matter how
you feel about finances what are you
going to do about it are you going to
rely on the economy to decide to dictate
your financial goals
not me please no